so you drove down to austin you got did
you guys shoot or kill anything
afterwards unfortunately no but we were
actually all of us
uh we were a little couple days after
him we're up in utah elk hunting
and so everybody got their their elk up
there and now it's time to get the back
straps and throw them on the barbecue i
mean if you want to invite to come back
to texas you let me know i got
i got thick boy food waiting for you bro
don't
don't tempt me i'll look for any excuse
to get to texas especially right now
dude the relocation of people right now
is
absolutely [ __ ] insane i mean all the
houses in this area
and like the five plus acres are getting
bought up you're having transpose from
la and cali coming out here i mean it's
it's i think everybody's in that kind of
field of thought that wait everything's
kind of conditioned to be
vtc and internet based now rather than
events so
and i travel for events and so i think
that's this thing is going to shape the
future of america and business
for like forever i don't think it's ever
going to go back to
how it was before but and i think for
the better man i really do i think for
the better
but what i what i find interesting i
shouldn't say funny what i find
interesting
is so many people are moving to austin
right but joe rog
all these people and i'm just not i'm
not picking on rogan in particular but
so many people that we know our buddies
and our circle so many people are moving
to austin
and like yeah forget la there's such a
democratic liberal state i'm moving to
austin i'm like have you been to austin
it's pretty liberal man it's pretty yeah
it's boulder
but with guns you know what i'm saying
like it's pretty little boulder
yeah well that's like a kind of a fear
of mine and not to be a tin hat where
but it seems that there's a lot of
people that had this
um belief system as far as how taxation
and economics should work
and then it they were in a failed state
and failed
governed state however from a
municipality level or whatever up to the
to the whole state but
then they leave and they bring that kind
of same economic
uh ideology to a properly run city i'm
like
hey maybe this is a learning lesson
where you don't bring your [ __ ] out
to us
and i'm not saying like we're perfect or
right but there's a reason that
you know we're not like a bunch of dead
right like our state so correct
maybe like [ __ ] off a little bit please
yeah it's a little weird right it's like
why how would you why would you bring
the same mentality that caused
you know the ruins in l.a over to texas
like the oxy didn't work man
so if you're just moving over here if
enough of you move over here
you're just going to shape the ideology
over there it's going to be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] show
but you guys maybe the silver lining is
will legalize wheat in texas finally you
know
uh other other than that you know i
think some people look at conservative
states as
oh they're so right-wing and then they
get to meet us they're like i don't care
who you [ __ ] i think it's great like
smoke weed like you know don't take all
my taxpayer money
and burn it that's kind of what i don't
want you to do
yeah i can't believe uh weed isn't legal
in texas yet
come on it's the only knock on texas
really
it is you know and i don't think it's
it's not the people's fault necessarily
i think it's more of all the lobbyists
you have with the tobacco industry and
the alcohol industry
and it's more of a pharma industries
yeah oh 100
you have millions and gajillions of
dollars getting dumped into
anti-lobbyists for marijuana is because
they don't want to get legalized because
people will wean themselves off alcohol
and opioids and be smoking weed and
laughing their ass off rather than
taking antidepressants every day and
i think that scares a lot of people that
are not vested in the american public's
health but they're vested in how much
money they can [ __ ] buy so they can
get their 19th yacht and you're like
come on man
yeah let the homie smoke some weed
together or at least decriminalize it
you're right man when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son